[Music]
are you okay yeah i'm just getting level
i'm still waking up a little bit but
yeah i'm ready i'm ready to go did my
mic sound fun by the way yeah i'm all
recording on my end so i'm good
my first memory of dark souls is the
bartholomew trailer which was the one of
the first trailers for dark souls and i
remember it because i remember watching
that trailer and thinking this looks
like my kind of game
it's a game that was
seemingly made out of things people
usually call
bad ideas i remember complaining that
there was no waypoint and i was like
well how am i supposed to figure out
where i'm supposed to go what i'm
supposed to do the world kind of seemed
a little bit boring to me
um because it's just you running around
in dirt and everything's grimy looking
i'd played skyrim before dark souls so i
was like oh yeah a fantasy game that's
you know colorful and green and luscious
then you can put in dark souls and it's
like no
depression dark souls is an acquired
taste people would would describe their
experiences and you would think this is
a negative review so selling that to
people is not an easy task and i failed
repeatedly out so the smarter thing for
me to do was just to buy the game
repeatedly and give it to people first
time i played it was more just a kind of
i'll fine i'll give it a go then
my first experience playing dark souls
um
was i think like a lot of people it was
being squashed immediately by the asylum
demon that like gave me a heart attack
at first i feel like i remember doing
the plunge you know that takes basically
half of health away and still not being
able to do it like to be honest with you
there's a lot of butt in your face right
off the get-go it's kind of slow and it
pretty much just sits on you like that's
like one of the things that it does and
the entire time you kind of got to stay
on the booty to beat it so like that's
that's pretty much the whole process
it's looking at the butt cheeks and
yeah the first time i saw a big chunk of
my health bar just vanished i was just
like oh no
got up to
the capra demon i got in the room and i
was dead within five seconds
and i thought
i'm never playing this [ __ ] game ever
again
fighting the capra demon on the train i
got so into it and i
very narrowly defeated him like with
like a slither of health left and i was
so excited that i kind of kicked out in
that excitement at the moment and like
struck the man that was sat opposite me
right in the shin but i didn't care
because i'd beat them kaepernick
it's a challenging game but fair in a
way that makes you come to accept it
first and then appreciate it afterwards
it's almost like a religious experience
where like you're totally engrossed what
seems completely impossible the first
time around gradually becomes more and
more possible it's so fun to look back
into and see the things that you got
stuck at that now you can do
effortlessly
and i think there's something so
universal about that
most action games i feel so overpowered
and the fact that the things actually
are as dangerous as they look in dark
souls
was a really cool feeling so any like
moment where like you say you're getting
back to the hub area you unlock a
shortcut is suddenly like it represents
a big
help
my favorite moment of the game it was
such a great moment it was when so when
you loop back to firelink shrine from
lower undead burke you find a ladder and
you're like well why why is this ladder
what's this for and then you kick the
ladder down and go down to see the
bonfire and then you realize
oh god it's the beginning of the area it
was just like it was like overwhelming
amount of like emotions of like wait
it's all connected i had this moment
where all of a sudden
especially because you can't warp in
dark souls at least you can't warp in
dark souls until way later in the game
so it made that linking
that much more amazing of a moment in
other games like those shortcuts don't
hit the same you realize that everything
has a purpose and a place and a pathway
it's all intertwined and designed in a
way that was kind of mind-blowing i love
that moment it's so good
i
am very glad
favorite npc is
they're all miserable
um
it's gotta be onion night you gotta love
the thick fat rolling boy just this
really happy kinda go lucky guy in this
really
desolate and depressing world
[Music]
i'm not going to say solaire because
everybody says solaire it's got to be
soleil it's got to be solar everyone
loves solaire for some jolly cooperation
always no matter what always go down
those little stairs to go giving him a
little visit to stare at the sun with
him just have a nice old time he is
encouraging jolly cooperation
he's optimistic and it's such a
refreshing character to you know be in
this game if i didn't know better i'd
think you had feelings for me i'm gonna
have to give it to law trek because
every time you talk to him he's like uh
yeah help me help me get out of this
prison cell and uh
i'll make it worth your while
and you're like okay
patches who's expecting that answer
nobody i like the fact that he tries to
[ __ ] with you all the time it's
hilarious it cracks me up he's such an
[ __ ] and it's amazing
and i'm so glad he's in every game
because he is the worst and best at the
same time i will never forget when he
pushed me off a ledge into darkness i'll
never forget it
this is what i do my friend
chester marvelous chester
i firmly believe that he slipped in
through a fissure he gets grabbed by the
hand and he's from yarn he's he's got
the top hat he's got a trick crossbow
he's wearing the hunter's set he talks
like a yharnamite i see the connection
does it really matter
[Music]
[Laughter]
frampt because
nothing that looks like him should have
his voice nothing that looks like him
should legally be allowed to have flaps
coming out of his lips he shouldn't be
allowed to put you in his mouth
[Music]
everything about him is disgusting and
wrong but also incredible and i love him
those who seek the realm of lords must
brave sen's fortress the player reaches
sends fortress after they have wronged
the two bells of awakening
then you're told that you first have to
traverse this house of
hodders
[Music]
[Music]
it's just so weird and filled with traps
i think it's so fun everything about it
is just great and it's also like the
very final step you have to take before
reaching anor londo
and orlando all the way baby that's like
one of the iconic all-time moments in
gaming history i think it was quite an
experience just i think emotionally it
was a hit but also visually it was
amazing and orlando looks like a
beautiful
uh spanish cathedral while it's still
new the aesthetic of it as a whole and
all the architecture and how like
glorious it looked was great
[Music]
then you hit ornstein and smoke
you enter the room you hear the music
you see five seconds of these two dudes
introducing themselves and that's all
you need to know
[Music]
as soon as that cursing drops on scene
just
dashes at you
ornstein like a rocket just comes
shooting in between pillars like a
dragon ball z character i was gaining
confidence then they threw this this
thing out of left field we have two
bosses at one time and i did not expect
that there's two bosses
and they're functioning independently of
each other this was the true roadblock
of the game with ornstein and smo this
is the get good moment ornstein and smog
is the boss that i hate about as much as
i love and i bet a lot of other players
say that too oh i hated it i hated
fighting ornstein's mom
they were so tough there's literally a
whole video documenting how many times i
said
during that fight
[Music]
no no
i definitely thought
this is unfair the first time i fought
him you know like the first time you
that you kill one of them and all it
does is make the other one more powerful
and refill all their health you're just
like
why are you doing this to me this is
this is
so stupid are you
ah
that's also like the most dark souls
thing ever it's just so good it's just
so good put your feet up because you're
gonna be here for at least the next five
hours when you finally get to the moment
where you beat them that's when that
cascading of everything that you've been
holding in for so long just falls out i
actually felt like we'd accomplished
something everyone who's played dark
souls
will remember
probably the moment that they'd beat
one's thing and smell i did it on my
first try i'm not even trying to brag
i'm not even trying to brag hardest
fight in the game no i don't agree in
the slightest
i love how dark souls bosses look like
they should just be able to step on you
but they don't the tourist demon ended
up
jumping off of
his arena and dying like instantly
[Music]
i didn't even find him
i think my favorite boss in dark souls
is actually
the bell gargoyles
it is the first time in that game where
you're presented with two bosses at the
same time as soon as people beat the
gargoyle it creates a feeling that you
can
go on
to beat the rest of the game
my favorite boss in dark souls is
probably artorias
being able to see artorias was kind of
like a big one for me he was just
amazing and stunning and all of his
glory he's a literal legend and i'm
fighting a literal legend everyone loves
artorias and i'm not hating on him i
love him he's probably the best sword
boss in that game he's got to be but
manus with the eyes and the extra long
arm he's just such a beast
i couldn't believe what i've been seeing
what a presence and event that whole
entire fight is not only from a gameplay
standpoint but from a lore standpoint
as you progress
as with all the souls games you discover
that not everything isn't what it seems
you discover the biggest betrayal of all
you meet gwenevere and you're like i
made it i am the prince i am the hero
turns out she's fake
[Music]
miyazaki almost will do this thing in
his games where like you'll unlock
something or find a secret world or like
get access to something in a way that
almost feels like a fake thing that you
read online somewhere it's stuff that
doesn't seem like it would make sense
but then when it happens you're just
like oh ashley is another one it might
be very small but i don't know i just
feel like it feels like a hidden away
little secret you hit one illusionary
wall and then you go and you have to hit
another one to find this giant
hollowed-out tree that you go down and
then music all of a sudden kicks in
which is nowhere else in the game for
the most part which just makes it that
much more awe inspiring just a really
cool place to experience and discover
for the first time especially when the
music kicks in just like
it's it's amazing i love ash lake i will
stick the [ __ ] up for blight down people
hate blight down i think it's one of the
coolest bits of the game the first low
point i remember in dark souls is
blighttown um which is probably a lot of
people's first terrible place it is a
jenga block tower of the worst
imaginable stacked on top of each other
and at one point in the game your job is
basically to get from the top of it to
the bottom of it oh i'll tell you my
least favorite bit the bottom of um
blighttown if that's a separate area if
you can count that
you just said you liked blighttown
you're standing up for the bottom of it
before that was the depths because i'm
pretty sure i got cursed everyone talks
about blighttown as being like this
like the worst place in the game and
it's this horrible poison swamp and all
this kind of stuff but
even to get to blight town you have to
go through the depths i was one of the
lucky people that once i went into the
depths which is the seaward level where
literally anything and everything will
kill you i got cursed which is a really
rough status effect in this game and
that might have been the only point
where i was like okay maybe maybe i'm
really doing something wrong
honestly it's like any time you talk
about it you're like oh it's such an
amazing game every part of it is
incredible except light town and then
past blighttown there's a bit in the
lava that's just [ __ ] terrible and
then but overall it's a masterpiece
i played it online so
i did play the pvp but not willingly
it's pretty rude
when people can just invade you and i
hated every minute of it i did play a
lot of the pvp in dark souls
and i apologize because i was an [ __ ]
getting that adrenaline rush with
someone would invade your game was so
cool and i loved it invading someone
else's world and being able to ruin
their day i've got 20 000 souls can you
just
like
i
was the awful person who did like a
really low soul level run and i was
invading like undead parish
[Music]
i was making my own fun in dark souls
pvp but it was mostly bullying but
that's dark souls
do i have a favorite piece of music for
dark souls i feel like this question is
targeted at me it's a pretty background
music that plays when you're at firelink
shrine
i don't know maybe just because i've
spent a lot of time there it just kind
of soothes my soul
i don't love the fire electronic music
because it's just music it's because
it's an ambience it's a a mood it's a
theme it's a narrative this is where i
feel good this is where i feel safe it's
my home
[Music]
the one that jumps into my mind at first
is the initial song that plays when you
fight the asylum demon at the beginning
i'm currently in the
process of creating a mod called lobos
sfx where i replace every single piece
of audio in the game with my mouth
sounds
i bet a lot of the answers would be
gwen's theme the gwen music 100 gwen not
just because i heard it many many many
times just affectionately referred to as
plin plin plon it would be what the plin
plan plan i feel it's pretty iconic at
this point i still go back and listen to
that how's quinceanera
[Music]
miyazaki's really big on making these
really big orchestral
almost like operatic compositions
because he has like his composer that he
works with but i think that the gwen
one's so powerful because there's like
nothing
that piano is basically how gwyn really
feels which is that he's almost
pathetic but
still putting up a fight but the real
gwyn inside of him is like this again
man like seriously actually managing to
fight him and get through that fight we
cried out this is for solaire it was one
of the most incredible gaming moments
i've ever experienced
first time playing
when i beat the ending and lit the fire
[Music]
this is it
that's it
what happened
that can't be it can it i wanted more of
a cutscene that that's that's honestly
what i wanted i wanted it to be a little
bit grander it sounds so naive and
stupid now but i guess i was hoping for
finally getting some kind of a clear
explanation behind things
[Laughter]
i was so confused and i think that's
what compelled me to go look up lore
videos online from epic name bro
uh he's so good i loved it so i linked
the fire the first time that i played
the game and when i linked the fire
it clicked it's not really a oh that's
it it's more of a
oh
i remember on my facebook group
the people and it hated the ending they
were like this is it doesn't make any
sense i don't understand it and that's
actually how i started my youtube videos
was four people
in that pvp group so
we have gwen and he's kind of the center
of everything but he's not the oldest i
was like recording my my forehead with
my macbook camera being like no wait let
me explain this to you guys like well
it's not you know it's not it's not it's
not a bad ending like i promise it's
actually really good it was a different
way of telling stories in games that i
hadn't seen before and i like that
because i like when video games
tell stories in a way that other mediums
can't tell stories you really have to
change your expectation
um in the industry we call it game
learning it's a tricky and intricate and
complicated story only i know the truth
about your fate
the legacy of dark souls is quite an
impactful one so this is coming from an
industry perspective because i'm working
in the industry now it's changed a lot
it started a new type of game or a new
genre which is kind of rare it's almost
like a shorthand and if you say you know
something is souls-like
people who play video games know exactly
what you mean it's kind of a meme in
itself that everyone was like comparing
you know whatever game was coming out to
dark souls oh this is you know the souls
dark souls of shooters or the dark souls
of racing games or the dark souls of
property management simulators or
whatever what's interesting is how many
games are described as being like this
feels like it was influenced by dark
souls and they're not rpgs they're not
third-person combat games it's got to
the point where if a game is hard
inevitably there'll be someone that'll
be like oh it's like a
dark souls like hopefully its legacy
won't just be difficulty but
a good challenge to overcome dark souls
tells you exactly what you need to know
and then pushes you to go explore and
figure stuff out yourself and i think
games used to be more obtuse and dark
souls you know because especially in now
we have ubisoft like sorry ubisoft but
you don't have to have the ubisoft eui
hud with like all the tutorials and the
markers and the you know you don't have
to have that and it's such a immersive
style of um moving through a game that i
think it ended up bleeding over as a
habit i've been turning off hud features
ever since i got into dark souls things
like that it's more about just putting
you in this world and respecting the
player putting everything back into the
player's hands
after
a decade or two of
here's what you do player it's kind of
responsible for teaching people a whole
other language on how to play games
um
and that's just like scraping the
surface it's one of the most influential
games of all time one of the best games
i just think it maybe not only leaves a
mark in the gaming industry i think it
also leaves a mark in people's lives
i've got
tattoos of a bone wheel skeleton and
some onion bros head the elite knight
armor on my arm and it's one of the few
franchises that i love enough
to throw on my body i know a lot of
people play the souls games when they're
going through a tougher time and it
really does help them get through what
they're going through that feeling of
overcoming obstacles
that feeling of challenge
when you're in a low place
can be really helpful emotionally it's
gotten me through a lot of tough
experiences in my life because you can
just hyper focus on this game
and overcoming it it also just taught me
not to back down from those challenges
be okay with failure and continuing on
from failure and to persist
until
you succeed at what you're doing we
don't necessarily get a rule book on how
to figure out life some people will say
they have one like some of the people
that you encounter within the dark souls
lore and they're trying to figure it out
but we ultimately don't know
and we're just trying your best through
failure and maybe one day getting that
big success that makes us feel like it
was all worthwhile it's gonna kick your
ass it should but that's part of the
experience the feeling you get when you
overcome something that's taking you
hours or days
man you don't get that from any other
game there's nothing like the first
experience of playing the first dark
souls it's one of the games i wish i
could delete from my memory just so i
could play it again
so you'll only get one chance at it so
appreciate it
[Music]
you